so let's have a look at question one
together mmm now it's a bit of a mess so
we'll start to read but we're going to
stop very quickly because it's going to
be too much to hold into our heads will
need a better tool to understand it it
says a particle of mass four kilograms
okay so far so good that's okay moves
from rest under the action of a force
whose magnitude after blah blah blah
okay stop right now you could start to
write down conditions when T equals zero
etc etc etc but it's going to be much
easier to just try and chart what's
going on in terms of what is the
particle doing what kind of behavior is
it exhibited okay so if i graph velocity
versus time I hope that you'll see as we
progressed to the questions why velocity
makes sense as an access to choose okay
what is happening is thick well it moves
from rest okay so on my graph where
should I start I should start at the
origin right at time zero velocity is U
emotional rest under the action of
forces magnitude after and then it gives
you an equation okay now here's the
point it's it's moving it smoothly okay
it's it's it's speeding up okay oh it's
it's moving somewhere now the particle
moves and miseries and then it reaches a
certain speed 19.6 meters per second
okay then what happens the four ceases
so velocity is not going to change after
this right the particle continues at a
constant speed that speed for five
seconds so it looks like this there you
go so far so good remember this is not a
displacement graph not just place / time
this is velocity the thing is moving but
the velocity isn't changing okay so at
some time
which I don't know what it is it stops
the force stops acting right and then 45
seconds it moves at this constant R a
useless cause the rhetoric so whatever
this time is after five seconds that's
when the behavior changes again for the
final time it's then brought to rest so
it's better this is going to come back
there it's brought to rest by a constant
force of five kilograms wet brought to
rest so it's going to come down at a
constant rate like something like this
okay thicker I'm finished right start
from zero a4 start acting a gift to a
certain speed four stops five seconds
elapsed then a new force totally
separate you can see the equations are
completely different I taught it and
brings it back to rest I don't know
where it rests but it'll be some time
that I'll need to work out literal okay
so you can see here I have a piecewise
function right to make it a bit easier
for me I'm going to name these different
sections okay so i'll call this one
section one this one in section 2 and
then i have my last section okay let's
take them one at a time how far does he
go that's the question right so let's
have a look at a good result let's have
a look at the first portion first
portion now we start with force right
because they give us an equation for
force so I've got force equals m8 right
now for this part of it they give us a
force equation they say it's 6 minus 2t
kilograms wait now stop keyframes wait
mass that's kilograms acceleration
that's meters per second squared so this
side of the equation the MA side it's in
Newton's right but then this is not in
Newton's right it's naughty Newton's in
fact it's even kilograms rate which is
lying point eight times bigger
Newton's okay so i've got this scale
happening okay is that all right let's
think about this the force right the
force is 6 minus 2t kilograms wait so
that's why it's big I need to get this
is in Newton's right this site is a
Newton's and this side is in kilograms
way but I don't want them to be
different okay so if you like if I said
for instance you've got like X let's see
kilograms just think of weight okay
equals a thousand grams right so in fact
what sex in this case it's one right
because it's it's 1000 x grams ok so ive
got tiny tiny units over here and big
units over here so that's why i multiply
to compensate ok so kilograms weight are
bigger than Newton's in nine point eight
times bigger okay so that's where it's
going to go that okay good all right
then I have a massive for and I don't
know what acceleration is ok but that's
okay i can rearrange the sealants let's
divide let's see you if i divide this by
two and then i divide this by 2 i'll
have divided by four is that ok so I'm
going to exert get acceleration is 4.9 3
minus 2t you're happy with that ok now
where am I trying to go now i have an
acceleration equation and it's in terms
of time remember we have all of these
fancy ways of writing acceleration right
the question i'm trying to answer is
total distance so what do you think is
the most direct path to get there
hmm now I've got two piece of
information where I'm going like this is
my water trying to find and what I've
got it in terms of okay now it's in
terms of time so therefore if I'm going
to integrate I have to interact with
respect time so therefore that leads me
to think probably DV DT is the most
helpful way to say it okay if I'd
written like say V DV DX I then be like
oh okay I'm kind of stuck because I
don't have other things in terms of X to
go with that okay so there we go I've
got this now because other parts of the
proof of this are going to take them in
a while I'm going to cheat a little bit
and I'm just going to go straight to
hear I know there's a constant but you
can see why it's zero right can you see
why it's zero it's because i have this
value and so you can go ahead and you
can evaluate it not that big a deal
that's the velocity equation you go to
end with what do I do with this do I go
from here remember like what am I trying
to do i drop this thing into three
different parts of the journey right so
in order to work out how far I've gone
in this part of the journey or you kind
of need to learn how long your that part
the journey lasts does that make sense
so how do I know how will I work out
when the journey this part section one
how will I know when it ends oh good the
question says when the particle reaches
a speed of 19.6 you can read it off your
graph right so I can say right okay well
let's let's put that air me right now to
put six
this is what I'm try to solve now I'll
get a time namely I'll get time one
right that's what I'm going to get 19.6
/ 4.9 very conveniently is four ok so
now I've got three t minus t squared on
to rearranging tidying up to meet the
quadrat it could be easy to solve I
guess I'll x 2 2 squared minus 16 plus 8
equals 0 ok your factorizing you get
what t minus 2t minus 4 ok so you've got
two sensible solutions ok but of course
the one that you're after is this one
right because as soon as you hit that
you've hit the requisites speed ok it's
alright I guess what that would mean is
if it hadn't have stopped it would have
kept on increasing and then come back
down to 99.6 but we're not interested in
that part ok so I say okay T equals 2 is
the value of things so that's really
good I've worked out what this time is
what do I do with it what I'm trying to
find its displacement I'm only on
velocity so I've got to climb up the
ladder one more time I have a particular
value in mind I want to go from 0 to 2
so it's a definite integral right the
distance for section one is going to be
from Nora to or V DT right
okay so no big deal you can quench
through that I think the answer you
should come up with is this once you
integrate properly get the right
primitive and chuck in your upper and
lower boundaries okay and you can go
ahead and you can verify that so now
what do i do at this point well I only
did the first section of the journey
right the first two seconds now I have
to work out the rest of it okay so i can
say it well section 2 as it happens is
really easy it's kinda trivial right
distance distance the distance or this
part the journey distance at least as
far as i remember is speed times time
right speed times time five seconds is
how long he's going for that constant
part of a journey okay so five times
when i say 19.6 okay what is that it's
like I don't know five times 19 is 95 5
times point 698 I think that part's easy
last part okay now this part is very
similar to what we had here right again
they give you a force equation so I'm
still going to have F equals MA even
though it's a different force okay the
equation they give you let's see where
am i up to is that it's a it's a
constant force of five kilograms wait 5
kilograms ways now pause for a second
and look up five kilograms way it's five
it's nine point eight times bigger
what's the mass still for that hasn't
changed and then there's acceleration
right I'm missing something what am I
missing look carefully read the question
again if you have to what's wrong with
this line if something is drastically
wrong
uh-huh Why Why should there be a
negative it's very common sense when you
think about it what's this force doing
what's his foster it's speeding up right
it's spinning you're so positive
direction right but the question says at
that end point that I don't love that
it's then brought to rest so whatever
this force is doing it's got to get it
away from being at a closing speed get
this velocity back down to zero okay so
hence our negative right from there you
can solve okay I think I think that's
for you nine if I remember it right so
you've got that acceleration okay now
you have to be a little more cautious
because when you integrate you better
believe that constant 40 right how do I
work out what the constant
I just gave you a clue in case you
hadn't noticed how do i wake up the
constant cuz not zero I good I have a
condition that one right it has to be
this one because it's got to be in
section portion 3 right that's when this
rule takes over ok so i can say when t
equals seven right when t equals seven
this point there after the first journey
five more seconds then the velocity is
19.6 ok it turns out a bit cross the
numbers aren't very friendly but you
work out the concept and I think you
should end up with this yuck but at
least it's not a repeating decimal so
now I have the velocity equation for the
last part their journey ok the velocity
equation is this plus ok what I do in
this thing I do that think back to how I
don't with section one I want to get
towards integration but I don't know
what to integrate between I know where
to start right but I don't know what
this final end time is but it's not that
hard is it it's just like the question
we just looked at you've got to work out
when V equals 0 ok so you're going to
solve for V equals 0 here ok when V
equals 0 you go ahead punch in the
numbers i'm pretty sure it's 8.6 ok
don't check it confirm it but this is
not the hard part of the question this
is just the crunching part of the
question ok what do I do with this value
no seriously what do i do it's now
I have to integrate again just like I
did here okay so distance three it's
going to be the integral from where to
where seven to this new time that I've
just determined 8.6 that's the end of
the journey and here is my velocity
equation with respect to time it's a
little bit more Messier because unlike
here where you had a zero you can just
go tada it disappears okay but here you
still end up getting your calculator can
take care of it I'm pretty sure that's
what you land on okay that that's how
fire travels back towards okay you get
the idea so what's the answer I've got
distance 1 i've got distance too and
then I've got distance three you add
them all up and you get this which is
somewhat convenient but anyhow there's
you no mercy I think they ran it off to
one decimal place in the textbook that's
what they were looking for okay